[Music]
are you thinking nothing really you are
not thinking nothing yes I am is your
not a very thoughtful person yeah no way
that you were thinking I am never just
not thinking absolutely not I didn't
worry that you definitely don't I do
though I swear I have an analogy for
this go with me on this just walk with
me on this command like literally yeah
like literally walk with me I'm asking
[Music]
so the way I see it we organize our
thoughts differently from one another
your brain is kind of like this
spaghetti and your thoughts are like
this sauce my brain is kind of like this
waffle and my thoughts are like the
syrup now if you'll notice this syrup
and this sauce are the exact same amount
okay your thoughts cover your brain like
tomato sauce cover spaghetti noodles
when I pick your brain you're always
covered in thoughts me on the other hand
my brain is like a waffle my thoughts
cover my brain like syrup on waffle
squares note I mean yeah right well some
waffle squares wife syrup but some
squares will be totally empty so
sometimes when you ask me like what am I
thinking maybe you just got an empty
waffle square like I'm not saying I'm
dumb I'm not saying I don't have
thoughts I have lots of thoughts I just
compartmentalize and maybe have one
thing at a time this is almost
insightful
kind of it's a little bit insightful I
feel like it makes a lot more sense you
know and you're not gonna judge me so
much when you ask me do you have
thoughts not like No
[Music]